scheiße mann der erste sondern jetzt
praktisch verbrannt die am besten so der
erste steht dann klingt er zweitens
würde am meisten sinn machen
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video ja ich hoffe
natürlich alle hier sind wir das nicht
komisch was macht ich bin so blau
das geht jetzt jetzt ist besser leute
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut mir
auch ein besseres wetter
ich bin eben nach köln gefahren es ist
so brutal am regnen später jetzt noch
nach berlin also um 8 uhr
deswegen muss ich mich auch sehr beeilen
jetzt dieses video zu drehen aber ich
freue mich drauf weil das ist ein video
das ich wirklich schon extrem lange
drehen möchte ich halte es mal kurz vor
23 monaten kam ein video fünfmal
hintereinander beim selben pizza
lieferservice bestellen
[Musik]
das kann echt gut an
das wurde dann auch direkt zu übernommen
von dem frank rost schöne grüße an
dieser stelle
da habe ich auch noch mal darauf
reagiert war sehr unterhaltsam und sehr
viele leute haben mir geschrieben alex
bestell doch einfach zehnmal
gleichzeitig bei verschiedenen pizzerien
zehnmal ist echt viel wir werden mal
schauen wie oft es wird also das habe
ich mir für heute vorgenommen
an die leute die jetzt schreiben öl voll
essens verschwendung und so staub
natürlich werde ich eine pizza bestellen
der mahlgrad mittags ich möchte selber
eine essen vielleicht auch zwei und
getränke dazu damit ich immer auf den
mindestbestellwert komme dann schauen
wir mal ob viele von den halt
gleichzeitig kommen und sich dann so
denken hätte gabi was geben hier auf
also ich glaube es kann nicht witzig
werden wie gesagt idee kommen von euch
nicht von mir
wir gehen jetzt direkt mal an meinen
computer bestellen die sachen über
lieferando und dann geht es auch schon
los lasst aber sehr gerne jetzt schon
mal daumen nach oben da ich hoffe es
wird cool für mich freuen und wir sehen
uns so leute ja hier sitze ich jetzt ich
weiß bisher ungewohnte umgebung
ich habe ja hier also wir haben alles
umgestellt unsere wohnung deswegen ist
das jetzt hier so bisher provisorisch
talent und ich mache mich mal hier ein
bisschen größer und wir gehen jetzt mal
auf lieferando ich habe mich eben schon
mal das erste zusammengestellt wie
gesagt ich bestelle einfach immer
getränke dazu damit weil die kann man
einfach im kühlschrank stellen
und was von auch noch dazu sagen muss
alle pizzen ich will jetzt so bei sechs
betriebsstellen sag ich mal zwei davon
esse ich selber habe ich wie sie so von
die anderen gleich kommen noch zwei
freunde zwei mir noch übrig hier bei uns
um die ecke sind so supermärkte da sind
nochmal obdachlose den kann man auch mal
dann so eine pizza geben die freuen sich
darüber
all das ist auf keinen fall irgendwelche
verschwendung oder sonstiges das soll
ich jetzt nur sagen jetzt starten wir
und ich wünsche euch viel spaß
ich wünsche mir ein paypal-konto auch
viel spaß weil das wir jetzt gerade sehr
enorm belastet na ja sagt paypal
zahlungspflichtig bestellen ok also wir
haben jetzt gerade 14 48 und die erste
bestellung ist jetzt eingegangen das
gute ist es keine mittagszeit was
bedeutet diese schneller
also wer bestellt jetzt um die uhrzeit
pizza außer ich pizza vielen dank für
deine bestellung durchschnittliche
lieferzeit bei ungefähr 30 minuten
weiter gehts ja ich überlegt eigentlich
könnte man doch hier mal so mit käse
rand warum eigentlich nicht und die
nächste etage hier beim boom paypal
laden laden laden so zac bestellung
nummer zwei ist auch ein gegangen ich
bin so dunkeln
bisher läuft das krasseste wirklich wenn
alle gleichzeitig kommen weil die kommen
alle mit meistens also 90 prozent der
fälle kommen die mit dem auto und bei
uns hier kann man halt schlecht parken
sodann ist so voll das verkehrschaos
zwar ganz witzig ja schon immer darauf
dass der mindestbestellwert möglichst
gering liegt so bei 8 euro das ist dann
immer deutlich entspannter und salat
könnte man auch bestellen auf jeden fall
pizza paprika er kommt ja hier rein
damit
und jetzt so ein getränk von ganz unten
insgesamt habe ich jetzt gerade schon 27
euro bezahlt das gilt ja noch für drei
lieferungen und weiter geht's ich muss
sich beeilen weil die sollen ja
möglichst gleichzeitig kommen pizzeria
mahlzeit
da habe ich noch nie bestellt kommen das
geht auch noch kommen hier nehmen wir
mal ein salat apfelschorle geht um
bestellen
es ist schon verrückt ok paper sagt
zahlungspflichtig bestellen
weitere 10 euro 40 ärmer ja deswegen
seid mir nicht böse werden wir in diesem
video in drei firma werbung haben muss
ja auch irgendwie wieder reinkommen hier
habe ich noch nie bestellt panda team
service also was ist das denn
frühlingsrollen ja wieso eigentlich
nicht kann man ja mal probieren ohne
jetzt noch begünstigt alter coca cola 0
33 euro nur leute ich muss jetzt leider
folgen das machen die coca cola kommt
wieder raus und wir nehmen jetzt mal
chinesisches bier also da bin ich mal
gespannt was da ankommt kommen bestellen
wir haben jetzt schon bei sechs
verschiedenen lieferanten bestellt einer
kommt noch und das reicht dann also mehr
brauche ich auch nicht ehrlich das ist
doch schon viel so sagt bestellen wie
findet ihr eigentlich hier diese uhr im
hintergrund checkt auf jeden fall die
ganzen ruhig auspackt videos da habe ich
die nämlich mal so vorgestellt und wir
hatten noch ganz andere verrückte dinge
dabei auf jeden fall an schon nach
diesem video
vielen dank wir haben deine bestellung
erhalten also ich habe jetzt bei 6 27
verschiedenen lieferanten bestellt jetzt
werde ich gleich mal schauen wie ich das
am besten machen mit den kameras und
dann heißt es ja hier muss ich ungefähr
40 minuten warten
ich bin gespannt ich lasse die situation
ist einfach mal auf mich zukommen es
kann natürlich sein dass alle um eine
minute versetzt kommen das wäre ein
bisschen schade da hat man nicht so
leiste reaktion ein glaube ich aber es
ist halt alles riehl nicht so über den
preis also leute bis gleich okay ich
habe gerade einen anruf bekommen
ja genau richtig also ich habe keine
ahnung warum ich gerade angerufen haben
ist ja auch egal ich dachte jetzt eher
dass wir wenn dann das lieferando team
das wird ja sinn macht weil ich habe ja
bei den einzelnen pizzerien bestellt das
ist mal war es ja so da hat die pizzeria
mich dann nach dem dritten mal angerufen
und meinte so ob das jetzt wirklich echt
ist oder ob das ein fehler vom system
war aber ich hätte auf jeden fall dass
hier sind jetzt hier diese ganzen
bestellung die ich getätigt habt könnt
ihr hier sehen glaube ich hoffe ich mal
35 minuten 40 minuten 30
40 minuten fünf minuten 30 minuten auf
und ausschied 60 minuten also die liegen
alle halbwegs nahe beieinander
wir warten jetzt einfach mal ab was
passiert das hier ist die kamera die
einfach die tür film und ich
positioniert sie auch die kleine kamera
draußen im flur über messen auch leute
schild der erste ist schon da ich das
ding irgendwie voll schnell ich bin
nicht so der erste schon jetzt praktisch
verbrannt die am besten so oder erste
steht dann klingelt jetzt weiter nennen
das würde am meisten sind machen wir
stellen heute in frankfurt bei 1
kann man einem lieben weil ich hätte für
25 mal jemand nach unten
von anderen bis das war okay ist da
hier ist intel die sind sich auf jeden
fall entgegen gekommen ein wenig gefragt
geht ja richtig schnell heute ich habe
gerade noch vor 20 minuten bestellt auf
jeden fall habe ich jetzt geschafft die
kamera im flur zu positionieren
wir wollen ja noch andere menschen im
haus ist vielleicht ein bisschen blöd
aber gut was wir zu machen wollt ich
habe glaube ich die beste lösung
gefunden
ich lasse die kamera jetzt dastehen weil
im flur kann fast nichts erkennen weil
diese treppen stäbe dazwischen sind so
ich glaube da kommen die nächsten da
stehen zwei autos er ist ganz witzig
manchmal wird mir das verleiht ich
vergesse man also ein trinkgeld zu geben
das muss ich jetzt machen weil es ist
super wichtig wenn ihr bisher stellt
gibt am besten immer euro trinkgeld aber
so vorsichtig wie ich hab's schon mal
vergessen tut mir echt leid leute ich
sitze gerade in einer ecke also ohne
spaß die ersten beiden die kam bei nach
15 minuten und kam schon über zehn
minuten keiner mehr bisschen blöd
[Musik]
ich kann nichts machen die kommen alle
sucht heftig versetzt also jetzt fehlen
noch vier oder drei keine ahnung und ich
hoffe das wird jetzt ein bisschen besser
drückt mir die daumen hier damit es seht
getränke über getränke die man alle ganz
entspannung im kühlschrank
hier haben wir schon die erste pizza
muss ich sagen sieht das nicht so nice
aus leute selten so eine schlechte
gewissen
ich habe keine ahnung woher kam und wir
waren und wir waren
ich gucke ja schon aus dem fenster
manchmal halt und autos an
manchmal auch zwei steigt aber keine aus
fahren dann weiter
nein
und jetzt jetzt muss noch der zweite
kommt das gibt's doch gar nicht ich
warte jetzt kurz in der hoffnung dass
vielleicht der nächste kommt
ich glaube ich also das war auf jeden
fall der freundlichste hey mann
so viel pech muss erstmal haben das
nicht einfach zwei gleichzeitig um die
ersten beiden sind sie im flur
entgegengekommen
juli freut sich auf jeden fall
sicherlich über den ersten kurs die wir
haben schöne marke coca cola leute also
ich war noch auf diesen panda service
bus halt dann irgendwie chinesisches
birgit was ich aber auch noch sagen kann
wenn man so von lieferando sondern
berechnete lieferzeit bekommt ich habe
jetzt gelernt dann kannst du dich 0
drauf verlassen also wirklich gar nicht
manche kommen nach 15 minuten manche
kommen nach 25 minuten andere kommen
erst nach 50 minuten obwohl der 30
minuten steht sechseinhalb stunden
später leute was geht
ich habe jetzt mich dazu entschlossen
noch ein kleines update zu geben wären
das insgesamt schon fünf lieferungen die
hier angekommen sind ihr könnt ihr sehen
und zwei fehlen noch das problem ist sie
sind schon so heftig über derzeit also
ich war schon über eine stunde und zehn
minuten auf die und eigentlich waren wir
mit 40 minuten angegeben der andere
sogar 135 und was ich halt auch sagen
muss die chance dass die gleichzeitig
kommen stufe ich jetzt für sehr gering
ein weil wir haben von allen sieben nur
noch zwei die fehlen und ich meine
chance wird ja von lieferungen
zulieferungen die alleine kommt umso
geringer wenn ihr versteht was ich meine
schade man ich bin ein bisschen traurig
hatte vor ungefähr einer stunde und 20
minuten über lieferando bei ihnen
bestellt
alles klar danke danke heute folgendes
aufgrund also ich habe es jetzt so
verstanden
er ruft mir zittern also ich hab nix
schon jetzt moment ich schau mal rein
bei mir ins konnten aber alles klar
sonst setze ich mich mal mit für
lieferanten verbindung ist ein bisschen
komisch alles klar dann ruhig noch mal
an
[Musik]
ja nee alles alles gute dass er sich ich
wusste dann noch mal an ich hoffe dass
noch mal angucken
das dankeschön ciao leute ich sitze die
ganze zeit und warte auf die letzten
bestellungen und ich bin gerade extra
mir durchgegangen
also guck mal hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so das
geld ist alles von einem konto runter
ich habe keine ahnung warum diese
bestellung storniert wurden
also ich habe kein geld wiederbekommen
studio anrufen
so geht es nicht ich habe gerade mehrere
bestellungen getätigt und die
restaurants habe ich angerufen zwei
stück davon in köln und meinten das sei
storniert worden
das feld habe ich allerdings irgendwie
nicht wieder bekommen also sich auf ein
konto und woran lag das war nicht mehr
ich habe hier ein paar gäste wir sind
ich hatte halt insgesamt bei sieben
verschiedenen bestellt ach so ich habe
jetzt nur ich sehe gerade die mail aber
da habe ich gar nicht reingekommen
ja okay gut er ist jetzt auch eigentlich
schon so spät dann hat sich das erledigt
ist jetzt auch nicht so schlimm leute zu
mir echt leid also das hat jetzt eine
ganz andere wendung genommen
aber irgendwie ich kann jetzt auch nicht
mehr machen außer das video hier zu
werden ich hoffe es war trotzdem wird
sich der typ grad habe ich mehr gefeiert
also der seelsorger die denken die
allgemeine panik wenn da wäre mir
bestellt also leute ich hoffe ihr hattet
trotzdem spaß beim anschauen
wir sehen uns morgen 10 wieder ich habe
schon angefangen das video hier zu
schneiden weil einfach
man kam mehr und das fehlt noch so es
hat noch so viel gefehlt
das war's abonniert den kanal lockt
aktivieren und schöne grüße an dieser
stelle an lieferando ich bin kein
betrüger
ich bin ein ganz netter kunde ganz viel
bestellung und ich wollte auch ganz viel
geld dafür zahlen wenn ihr das nicht
wollt dann halt nicht